yeah i read a book a few years ago by an
author by the name of bill bryson
excellent author excellent book it was
called in a sunburn country and it was
all about bryson's adventure down under
in australia uh he he describes a
somewhat wild unpredictable but
beautiful place full of deadly dangers
but also bold outgoing and often quite
fearless freedom-loving people
over the last few weeks though you know
i've wondered
what an updated version of that book
might be given recent events
australia as you may have heard is in a
full lockdown because of coronavirus the
measure it has uh the measures taken are
among the most extreme in the world with
the military being called in to enforce
the rules in many of its cities
including in sydney which has had a
total of four cases
yes four
in a year okay four cases in a year and
the military shows up
in fact the whole country of 25 million
is experiencing
a rolling average of two coveted deaths
a day two a day
now if i were to venture to do some math
here which is usually a mistake by my by
my calculations a total of point zero
zero zero zero zero eight percent of the
population is dying of covet per day
and that is enough to justify a
military-enforced lockdown
and all of this while australia remains
a country absolutely chock-full
of scary deadly stuff that can kill you
there are more natural dangers in
australia than almost anywhere else on
earth outside of maybe the amazon
rainforest in fact covet has killed as
many people this year in australia as
animal attack attacks typically kill in
the same country
266 people were killed by animals in
australia between 2008 and 2017 making
about you know 25 or so a year
uh that's about how many have died from
covet this year in australia
by the way most of the animal deaths are
from horses and cows surprisingly which
means that it's uh it's not far from the
truth to say that the average australian
should be about as afraid of livestock
as he is of covet they might as well
shut down the country and and call in
the military over a loose cow roaming
the streets somewhere but don't expect
the authorities in charge of australia
to have this sense of proportion any
more than the authorities in charge of
the rest of the world have a sense of
proportion here is the health chief of
new south wales dr carrie chant
giving a master class in
disproportionate responses watch this
we all need to work together
we need to limit our movements
we need to consider whenever we leave
our house that anyone with us
and anyone we come into contact with
could
convey the virus
so
whilst it is a human nature to engage in
conversation with others
to be friendly
unfortunately this is not the time to do
that so even if you run into your next
door neighbor
in the shopping center in the coals
while you're at coleslaws or aldi or any
other grocery shop
don't start up a conversation
now is the time for minimizing your
interactions with others
even if you've got a mask
do not think that affords total
protection we want to be absolutely sure
that as we go about our daily lives we
do not come into contact with anyone
else that would pose a risk
the virus is out there anyone can have
it everyone is a threat everyone could
kill you do not engage not don't speak
to anyone don't have conversations a
conversation could kill you
if your neighbor tries to say hello
shoot him in the face
and then run and lock yourself in the
basement your lives depend on it
now i listen to that and um
you have to understand i am actually in
favor
of banning small talk okay i'm in favor
of sending in the military to stop
people from having small talk
conversations i already do avoid having
interactions with people i already have
adopted a policy of using lethal force
on anyone who attempts to have a
conversation with me i already am
unfriendly
i already am a fascist dictator so this
should all be music to my ears
in fact i should be volunteering to go
to australia and use my expertise to
help enforce these rules but
avoiding conversation due to a generally
anti-social disposition
is far different from avoiding it due to
a suffocating fear that having a
conversation will literally kill you
i can understand and endorse the former
not the latter
but the scariest thing here as always
is not the insane rambling of dr chant
with the new south wales health office
there have always been power mad
sociopaths in position of power
inevitably those are the kinds of people
who typically seek positions of power
this is the case everywhere and for all
time which is why our system was was not
put in place to attract specially
virtuous politicians there is no such
thing but instead to protect us against
the megalomaniacal idiots who would
unavoidably end up in those positions
unfortunately
that system hasn't been working as well
in recent times and in any case that is
not what scares me the most in this case
what scares me are all the average
people however many millions of them who
do not see any problem
with locking yourself away and avoiding
all human contact treating human beings
as plague carrying rodents for fear of a
virus that has infected four people in
your city in a year and killed none of
them
many millions in australia and here and
across the world have lost their ability
to think rationally about this or most
anything else
talking to them feels very much like
like the conversations i have with my
daughter when i've tried to convince her
that there's no monster in the closet
i mean her fear and her imagination
override any rational analysis or
investigation of the question which is
fine for an eight-year-old i can
literally open the closet
and show her and say look see there's
there's nothing in here
okay just mounds of clothes on the floor
because you can't be bothered to hang
them properly as i've told you a million
times in fact you know what maybe there
are monsters under that mound of clothes
you know yeah yeah yeah hang the clothes
so that monsters don't hide under it how
about that
anyway we've gotten sidetracked but the
point is that children can be childish
in that way and that again is fine
it is not fine for grown adults
we live now in a world of adults
cowering in fear because of the monsters
in their closets and all of those adults
especially the ones running australia
are canceled in fact the whole country
of australia is cancelled if you people
want to be afraid of something be afraid
of the spiders in your country you have
spiders literally raining from the sky
threatening to crawl into your ears and
eat your brain that's a rational fear
focus on that instead
in the meantime
you're all canceled
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now i thank you for your
compliance it is
somewhat appreciated